joining me now is ellard stromie a
spokesperson for the israeli embassy
here in the united states
thank you so much for coming on the show
tonight uh given 500 palestinian
children were killed in the 2014 gaza
war according to both
the un and human rights groups how
worried should we be tonight that israel
is about to launch
another full-scale assault maybe an
invasion of gaza
thank you maddie for inviting me i think
the question you are asking is something
to refer to
hamas spokespeople because eventually
the reality on the ground is that
quiet will be responded by quiet if
hamas is going to continue to threaten
israeli civilians
for firing rockets indiscriminately
towards israeli towns
uh then we're going to be forced to
respond and respond forcefully and by
the way this is not just israel
any country in the world would have done
the same if their cities were
attacked under constant attack by
rockets by terrorist organizations
i mean i mean any country in the world
most countries in the world
are not in charge of a decades-long
military occupation but you mentioned
hamas rocket strikes i think we can both
agree that hamas firing rockets at
civilian buildings is wrong
can we both agree on that i think we can
agree on that right that's common ground
for us
hamas firing rockets you have to be
wrong there is
really agreement with us on that agreed
you got me
100 we agree and yet today you had a
13-story residential apartment building
in gaza targeted by the israeli air
force destroyed how is that not anything
other than a war crime a deliberate
attack on a civilian target
you know i think it's a actually very
disfortunate that people are trying to
equate
the idf response to hamas as a terrorist
organization
israel acts in accordance to the
international law
we target only hamas targets and every
target that we're
firing at is being chosen very carefully
we do that with accordance of
international law in order to
minimize civilian casualties and
collateral damage
and you know what we're the only country
and the only organization the only ones
in the middle
east that actually care about
international law hamas
doesn't care palestinian islamic jihad
doesn't care and
every loss of life but unfortunately
you've flattened i mean we we don't we
don't have time to get into an argument
about international law suffice to say
that most human rights groups criticize
israel for violating human rights law
and they criticize hamas
but you leveled an apartment building i
think you gave them a one-hour warning
to get out of the building
you think that's in line with
humanitarian law to bomb a civilian
apartment building in gaza
you know hamas is using the palestinians
in gaza as human shields
they're firing rockets at israel from
within centers of civilian population
because they want to see these sites
they want to force israel to respond
and to see their sides now also hamas
and the palestinian authorities are
exaggerating with the numbers
you were mentioning earlier in your show
about the casualties and the
children that were killed uh and you
said that it was results of the
idf strikes but we know for a fact
that six of these children for example
were killed
because of hamas rockets were misfired
and fell
in with bigger gaza swamp and they
killed the palestinians
so i'm taking any report just to be
clear i i just want to be clear here
ella
i just i just i just wanted to be clear
let's find common ground are we now
saying is your position because i'm sure
militant groups are listening in from
across the world
is your position that apartment
buildings are fair game if there's
someone inside you don't like is that
the position of the early government
tonight you know you say that you don't
want to go into international law but
the question that you're asking is
exactly a question of international law
it's a question of what is a legitimate
target it's a simple question
are apartment buildings okay to bomb
because i'm sure hamas will say that the
military
target then it's a legitimate strike if
hamas is using the target
in order to hide weapons in order to use
it as a a
commanding a a post okay
but you said you don't want to go there
so so
okay i mean it was an apartment building
with hundreds of families and you told
them to leave so you knew there were
families in there
gaza of course has erupted because of
what's happened in east jerusalem
with the expulsions of palestinian
residents hold on let me ask my question
let me ask my question then you can
respond your government says what's
happening in east jerusalem is a private
real estate dispute
even though under international law the
united nations u.n resolution 478 which
even ronald reagan didn't veto
makes it very clear that the world does
not recognize israel's occupational
annexation of east jerusalem
in fact u.n officials said on friday
that your government could be guilty of
possible war crimes in east jerusalem
under the geneva conventions as an
occupier transferring its own population
into occupied territory
you know these lies being perpetrated
toward israel is old
and they're not new and the reality is
that we are
a law-abiding country and right now the
dispute in sheikh
in is something that is being discussed
in the israeli courts it's not yet
decided that they is totally they
decided and what we have tried to do to
do is actually to de-escalate the
situation on the ground
and it was supposed to be discussed
today in the supreme court
which is the highest abiding a law
in israel and we have asked the supreme
court to postpone it
because we wanted to de-escalate the
tension on the ground but the reality is
this is not
the israelis everybody is trying to
escalate
the situation the palestinian authority
hamas is igniting the situation and and
trying to prevent any solution you say
to the problem
okay you made that point you say you're
a law-abiding country i put u.n
resolution 478 up on screen passed in
1980
which the reagan administration did not
veto which says that your occupation and
annexation of east jerusalem
is illegal under international law 14
u.n security council members voted for
it that's not
lies that's international law and human
rights watch bet salem
which is israeli human rights group
they've all in recent months accused
israel for the first time of the crime
of apartheid
and i know you vigorously reject that
discrimination that description
sorry of the discrimination that
palestinians endure but how would you
describe
these quotes from the deputy mayor of
jerusalem arya king
a settler leader who told the new york
times on friday that these evictions are
quote
of course part of a wider strategy of
installing
layers of jews his words throughout east
jerusalem
so okay it's not apartheid what would
you call that
so you know the deputy mayor of
jerusalem is a politician from different
politicians
parties i speak for the government the
question is
who does he speak for and there are
different opinions in israel with
different
thoughts about how to approach that and
the reality is that
you're trying to make the shaykh a
dispute of
five families that needs to be resolved
i'm not undermining five six families
that needs to be resolved
as the core of the issue and this is not
the core of the issue
the core of the issue is that they have
deeds that prove
uh that they own the land and there were
compromises being offered to the
families who lived there
and they refused to those compromises
because they were incited by the
palestinian authorities because they
wanted us to get to where we are
if we're going to get enough we're
trying
supreme court ruling on that to see
what's uh going to happen with that
understood but if we're going to get
into
the legal if we're going to get in touch
maybe if i may i want to say something
if we're going to get into property
hold on we're almost out of time if
we're going to get into if we're going
to get into property deeds i'm sure
there's a fair few
thousands of palestinian families who
have property leads and keys which are
not being honored by the israelis but
you say he's just a deputy mayor i mean
that's an elected official another
deputy mayor of jerusalem fleur hassan
nahum
told the times quote this is a jewish
country there's only one
and of course there are laws that some
people may consider as favoring jews
it's a jewish state again you say
apartheid is a wrong description how
would you describe such language
from two deputy mayors elected two
deputy mayors of jerusalem
two deputies they were about you say we
don't have time
but you're taking what she said for
example i assume
out of context because israel is a
jewish state and is the national
homeland of
all jews but every minority and every
group
enjoy equal rights under the law that's
not what she said
she said some laws favor jews that's not
what the quote says
he talks about some laws favoring jews
and says that's the right thing to do
would you condemn that language you say
you don't speak for these deputy mayors
would you as an israeli government
official
condemn israeli officials who talk about
some laws favoring jews
putting layers of jews in east jerusalem
you can condemn it tonight and say you
don't speak for them
would you maybe many what i want to do
is to condemn
everyone who is trying to flare a very
fragile in a very uh
sensitive place and this is what
extremists from the right in israel are
trying to do
extremists from the right uh in the
palestinian authority extremists from
the left everybody is trying to do that
and we need to try and find a way to
de-escalate that
the israeli government has done
everything that we can de-escalated
in up of ramadan of jerusalem day
and right now we're following giving all
the lies
uh and and i want to say one more thing
because i think we're about to give it
out of time hold on hold on
no no no i need to get i need to you're
giving i'm letting you give very long
answers we're out of time one last quick
question you talk about de-escalation
that's
hundreds of palestinians in hospital
tonight might disagree with that
description
but opposition to the israeli government
is growing in the u.s
betty mccollum talking about her bill to
prevent u.s taxpayer dollars
from being spent in the occupied
territories even your own former
ambassador to the u.s ron durmer
said over the weekend that israel should
prioritize the passionate and
unequivocal support
of evangelical christians over that of
american jews who he said
are disproportionately among our critics
that's a pretty damning admission isn't
it
you know i'm not going to comment of my
former boss who have
uh high appreciation towards him but i
will tell you as an israeli official who
speaks to you on an official capacity
right now
the jewish community is very important
for us and we're working tirelessly to
work with
both sides of the jewish community
liberals and conservative
and also non-jewish communities
evangelical christians is one of them
but not only
african-american communities latino
communities the
support of israel in the united states
is very important
with all the fabrics of the american
society
and we're totally out of time so one
last question yes or no i can only take
a yes or no
you speak for the israeli government
does the israeli government support a
two-state solution
we promised under the trump peace plan
to keep the path
for us uh palestinian statehood open and
this is the policy of the israeli
government
so not a yes ella stromer thank you so
much for your time tonight i appreciate
it
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe
below to stay up to date on the day's
biggest stories thank you for watching